let's get into this level of bribery
this level of desperation spin a wheel
as they promote the
vaccation can I spin the
wheel to B all right come on down
everybody spin the wheel and get a flu
we're living in a dystopian world right
now some Bizarro world movie kind of
like um idiocracy come on down get your
seed we're going to pump you full of
chemicals that has already been proven
has harmful side effects you know they
used to say when it first came out that
it was 100% effective 100% safe and by
the way sign this waiver we're going to
give you a donut we're going to pay off
your student loans if you'll just take
this please we're begging you we're
bribing you 19 test penss that look like
an addtion talk about propaganda this is
next level pedite I'm sure there's
poison in this stuff suc get your drink
the sugarfree Kool-Aid represent your
Band-Aid no don't listen to that